hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 1 of on duties his work on stoic
ethics Cicero examines courage one of
the four cardinal virtues and one of the
aspects of courage that not only for the
Stoics but but really for all the virtue
ethicists in ancient times courage was
associated with was a kind of mastery of
emotion or a fact generally this was
associated with fear you were courageous
or brave or had fortitude in Latin
fortitudo by engaging in activities that
were scary that that required you either
not to feel fear or to master the fear
that you felt and to do what was
necessary in those circumstances despite
being afraid in circumstances where many
other people might give in to that fear
Cicero has a very interesting treatment
here and it's in consonance with the
Stoics in that bravery or courage
doesn't just apply to fear or to
confidence the opposite of fear instead
it has to do he says with a number of
other emotions in addition to fear so
fear is not being left out of the
picture as a matter of fact it's still
quite central but courage as a virtue
for the Stoics is going to involve
resisting or overcoming other forms of
emotion or activity so in chapter 20 he
says that we must keep ourselves free
from every disturbing emotion the Latin
for that is para to Bozzio and that's in
some respects a technical term not every
one of what we would call emotions
actually fits under this rubric of per
to bacio just the disturbing emotions
the emotions that are excessive the
emotions that don't have a good purpose
in leading us to our end the emotions
that caused trouble for us and and
indeed lead to a troubled mind so the
ones that he's talking about here all of
these are examples of per to bacio nays
that is the plural for for that or
disturbing emotions he says we must keep
ourselves free from these not only from
an already here he's talking about two
emotions desire and fear but also from
excessive that's the translator putting
that in there pain and pleasure and from
anger so there's already five different
emotional modalities that are being
brought under this this virtue of
courage and we'll see why in just a
moment he says that there is a purpose
to this so we may enjoy that calm of
soul and freedom from care which bring
both moral stability and dignity of
character so why does he construe things
in this way why do the Stoics in general
construe things in this way because
remember Cicero's getting this from pen
anteus so we want to be free from these
disturbing emotions one of the other
things to point out is that that Cicero
understands courage to also encompass
something that a few other people
particularly the Aristotelian 's saw as
a separate virtue greatness on Soler
greatness of mind Cicero will talk about
this as on imme magnitude oh you know
literally greatness of the mind or or of
the spirit and what is that that is a
capacity to rise above the things that
would otherwise bother and bedevil
ordinary people so this is an integral
part he thinks of courage courage
involves a certain type of independence
from the things that tend to embroil
other people in reactionary States in
simply doing things to you know get out
of fear get you know satisfy their
desire Cicero says that this is what
gives us
freedom so courage and freedom are
closely connected together so let's talk
about fear may choose in in Latin well
this is one that that like I mentioned
other virtue ethicist certainly talk
about you know from Plato and Aristotle
onward and we we want to try to at least
minimize if not talk ourselves entirely
out of a train ourselves entirely out of
feeling fear when we don't need to feel
it now the Stoics did think that there
was something called rational fear or
caution you LA baya and Greek and that's
that's a reasonable fear to feel but
most things that we fear are not in
themselves fearful or dreadful and so
Cicero thinks that you know we ought to
try to overcome that and that's what
courage does now I do want to say one
thing here Cicero not only says that
this involves not avoiding danger so you
know the fire person who runs into the
burning building is you know going to be
at least on a physical level afraid of
the fire that they're encountering
because fire is scary' you know but they
overcome that and they rush in Cicero
also says we don't want to swing to the
other extreme and here you can see a
reflection of something that Aristotle
himself made you know very clear that we
don't want to fall into rashness and
indeed many people who are rash or
foolhardy who seem to display no fear
and who run into danger may do so
because they're afraid of something else
they're afraid of looking bad they're
afraid of social you know forces they're
afraid of of their own identity or
unresolved identity as a tough guy or
somebody who's resolute or somebody
who's resilient and so they take on more
than they they ought to so fear is is
definitely one of the emotions that
courage bears upon why does this Roe
talk about desire Kapiti toss
the desire for you know say wealth or
sex or food or honor or social status
you know property sister actually
sometimes talks about houses people
having a desire for nice houses and
furnishings or something that Cicero
himself encountered power to be in
charge to call the shots
courage involves standing up against
that and this is where that that
greatness of soul part I think comes in
it involves an independence from these
desires that tend to steer other people
into things that are quite troubling so
courage has to do both with fear and
desire but then he goes on and he says
courage also has to do with pleasure
Wolle PLAs and Latin the word that we
get you know voluptuous from right and
pain or if you want to translate it as
grief or anguish I go toe to toe right a
very nice word there it's got a kind of
sense of you know piquancy to it doesn't
it they that I agree you know if you
know your your Latin so why would he
talk about these why is pleasure and
pain a problem that courage would have
to bear on well cicero thinks that that
you know we shouldn't be overcome by
pleasure and he doesn't just mean desire
for pleasure
he means the experience of pleasure it's
one thing to desire pleasure you don't
have the pleasure yet right you want to
go and eat the nice meal you want to go
and have sex with this person you want
to you know you're looking forward to
when you get to be in charge or
something like that the pleasure is
something that you actually do
experience that can carry us away
normally we look at pleasures a good
thing the more that we have of it you
know the better it is for us but the
Stoics said you know some pleasures can
actually lead us into all sorts of
problems likewise they saw pain or grief
or you know other ways of having
disturbing mental or if you like
spiritual states as a real problem they
didn't see any good in that the the the
good life is one that's free of those
sorts of things so they're not talking
just about physical pain as a matter of
fact physical pain is the least of it
they're talking about mental pain cycle
psychological pain and this is something
that the stomachs thought we ought to be
able to bear ideally we wouldn't have
any of that in our life but we are
probably going to encounter a good bit
of it so courage is what allows us to
deal with it to encounter it and move on
courage is what provides us with
resiliency this is a very important
point
courage is what leads us not just into
dangerous situations but helps us get
through difficult situations and pain is
really central to that the last emotion
that he's referring to here and he talks
about it a good bit later on is that of
anger in Latin era or in that passage
Udrih kun diya really meaning the same
thing and why does he reflect on this
well because there's a tendency that
many people have to confuse anger the
state of being angry and it's a very
active state it seeks out retribution it
attempts to right the situation the way
that the angry person
you know conceives of writing the
situation which generally involves
imposing some sort of penalty or pain or
or vindication upon the other person or
persons who made one angry many people
mistake that for displaying courage why
because they're both active because they
both respond to threatening situations
or situations in which injustice has
taken place or at least appears to have
taken place Cicero stresses to us over
and over again on the
the classic stoic stance that anger is
not the same thing as courage and that
if we mistake the two of them for each
other we are actually setting ourselves
up for all sorts of problems and you
know if you think about it if we are
getting involved with with other people
as well teaching them leading them we're
also raising issues for them by our bad
guidance so he says we shouldn't listen
to those who thinks that one should
indulge in violent anger against one's
enemies and imagine that such as the
attitude of a great spirited brave
person why nothing is more commendable
nothing more becoming in a pre-eminently
great person than courtesy and
forbearance he says in a you know
community we have to be ready to forgive
insults he says we must school ourselves
to affability and what is called mental
poison I rotated when people intrude
upon us we will develop a sour churlish
temper and gentleness of spirit and
forbearance are to be commended he says
so you can be courageous without being
angry as a matter of fact from Cicero's
perspective if you are getting angry
you're not courageous because courage
would curtail that anger courage would
do what is right without having to be
motivated by that form of affect and it
will get more done as a matter of fact
and more reliably as other Stoics point
out to us
so you see courage bears on quite a few
of the emotions from the stoic
perspective
you